welcome to the next part of the deform
repertoire series this is some already
part 11 and it deals with various setup
some involved in the move c5 public
mostly of course this is some called
Benoni
in some way been only defense and i'm a
modern Benoni and also on the banco
volga gambit first let's take a look at
the modern Benoni which is the most
common form actually with the suggested
repertoire this is not a big problem I
think I already mentioned this if leg
goes for this setup you can at this
point exactly at this point at move
seven just play according to the line
you already know from the Kings Indian
so you either go f3 if you play the
Samish h3 and Bishop g5 or f4 so the
modern benoni is some yeah just just
part of a repertoire from the white
point of view because we have some line
against the kings in yen so what other
options are there to reach a bin only
set up of course black at this point can
choose to go on g6 as well and delay any
commitment in the center this is also no
problem because again at this point you
can choose according to your line
against the Kings Indian f3 f4 or h3
it's it's that easy
okay so what kind of baloneys are there
beside that yeah they're the so called
the aclu's Bologna's are check iannone's
check iannone's from the Czech Republic
holy okay
what form of this is the move e5 at this
point
93 d6 d4 and blacks idea here is to
completely close the center and then try
to go for play on the flank on the other
wants to go at some point
f5 often prepared by g6 of course and
another idea would be to go b5 at some
point there are many good setups here
I'd like to recommend one there should
be seven then g3 castles and h4 this is
some not played that often but has a
very impressive score for white the idea
is just to show a couple of more moves
to get the bishop to h3 and this has the
benefit of exchanging the yeah possibly
bad bishop because white has got all
pounce on white squares and blacks
Bishop is from a theoretical point of
view the bet the good bishop what has a
very nice space advantage here and
usually it's it's a good idea to may to
mainly play against Blacks ideas just
prevent b5 and make it hard to play f5
and then you will often end up with a
position with the huge space advantage
the idea with h4 also has the benefit of
preventing on blacks plan of Bishop g5
to exchange his bad Bishop of course
it's not possible with the phone on H
form this is a good line it's a good
idea to study
some games some with the structure it's
not much about concrete um move orders
here but about finding a good plan the
idea was a five can also be played
earlier exactly here if black starts
with c5 white goes d5 as well and at
this point if five this is similar play
continues II four six but now it's a
good idea to avoid c4 at this point it's
of course it's playable it's not to
better something but in this position
black can do without the move Knight f6
and has good chances to really get this
Bishop exchanged and this would help
black of course a lot so it's it's an
idea here to actually play Knight to c3
which also has the advantage of leaving
the see first we're open for a piece
preferably the night which often takes
this route and that's very good position
on c4 so and that is really good idea
here another related area which is also
and also good is - to give the check
here and then later goes for set up with
Nazi three um I won't show I'm too many
concrete moves yet it's it's a good idea
ready to to pick out some some games
played in this line on by good white
players say um good grandmasters with
2500 and above and see how they play
this and pick up some little game plans
you cannot learn a concrete great line
against those close setups this is also
often the idea that black has with
playing this
opening it's it's very closed it's a bit
passive but it well it cannot be killed
outright with some sharp line like just
wants to get a playable game and
maneuvers pieces so it's a good idea to
pick up some plans from whites point of
view um what else is there with c5 black
might consider to go back here to the
ideas of the modern be known he was a
six you could just answer C form if you
want to UM save some some time and
transposed to regular modern benoni but
in this creep position also Knight c3
and also e4 good moves one funny line
that I often getting inlets especially
is this one which often leads to a
direct win because black is simply
overlooking this little check here okay
but it's it's it's rarely played but but
it happens okay I think this is almost
there will be no need complex on what
one line I forgot one line that can also
be a bit tricky and start with e six
here if you then go c4 which is of
course the sensible move for abattoir
black might try c5 here now d5 he takes
DC DD six Knight c3 g6 which looks just
like a regular beam on him but black
hasn't played a knight f6 yet so he
might consider actually placing this
night on e7 or h6 this can be an
interesting idea on but actually this
line has been played by a couple of good
grandmasters to power for instance try
this a couple of times he plays abalone
anyway and this is
sort of a tricky way to reach us
structure he's familiar with um actually
it's it's a good idea here to to well
have a look at this because some lines
are maybe not as good as they are with
knight on f6 for instance f3 maybe isn't
such a great idea because one idea that
black has against this kind of setup in
the middle game is f5 with the king and
the King's Indian Black has played the
knight on f6 so Oh in the in the regular
modern Ben Oni
so he needs to move this night away and
then play a 5 and here black actually
might just play 97 and then go f5 in the
very near future and this looks a little
bit clumsy for white if black quickly
goes for a 5 so it's a good idea to to
either play with with f4 um what would I
like to recommend most specialty 3 and
black often flicks in a six a four not a
c7 and then h4 and this is it's quite a
nice reward if black castles now then
you really have got h5 and this is
dangerous for black so very often there
follows h5 and Bishop g5 this is a
really rare line it's very unlikely that
you face it but you should know really
that you should take care exactly in
this position that that f3 maybe is not
not a really good move here
there should be three or setup was f4
are better I think okay now the other
and the most popular way of playing c5
at some point of course as the Benko or
Volga gambit starting with C 55
and b5 of course yeah this opening is is
popular up to a certain level of players
but this it's basically not played at at
world-class level the reason is mainly
that white takes a pawn not this time
white takes a pawn and then plays very
sophisticated setups to really well
fight blacks temporarily initiative and
try to convert the porn later for
instance it is very popular to to play
to play to the g3 line and it's it's
difficult for black there but this line
doesn't really fit ensure the repertoire
I'm proposing here because it really
involves very tedious maneuvering and
it's it's the kind of position where a
player like up off maybe it's cause 90
percent or so but it's difficult for a
normal player so to say to to play this
so my suggestion here is to to play b6
at this in this position and return the
pawn immediately um this has the
advantage that the Queen side especially
the a they file stays closed there are
mainly two ways for black to play and
now the either goes for a standard setup
with g6 and g6 capturing first and then
hmm
play along this line and this is a
rather nice position for white to play
he's got c4
that's a nice square for the knight and
we'll just develop normally this is a
sample line which is i think slightly
better for white black doesn't have this
really clear counter play and with
automatic moves that he often has in the
bank Oh like Queen f5 rook
to be a dad just put everything on the
queenside whites position in the center
is quite solid and you can try to break
through later with e5 at some point or
even play on the Queen side sometimes
depending on what black will do in the
future um this is a bit better for white
a lot of specialists of the Bangko
therefore play east six here and try to
get direct counter play this often leads
to I just present one line which is the
main one
let's just go to this position after
move thirteen of course why does it have
an extra pawn but he's got a very
healthy and sensible development and
he's got play against weaknesses on d7
maybe a6 has also big at some point it's
got very nice bishops I think white is
somewhat better here
um if you intend to play b6 against the
Benko it's a good idea to look at the
games of Alexei dray F again play I
already mentioned the very nice model
player to look at for other Kings Indian
lines and generally it's got a very well
thought-out and sophisticated opening
repertoire with white based on d4 so if
you don't know what to do against a
certain line it's sometimes just a good
idea to look up what dray F is playing
and most likely it is a good line yeah I
think that's it for for the c5 systems
um yeah if you liked the video um it's a
good idea also to subscribe to my
channel it's for free there's no cost or
something
um involved there but you'll get notices
when the serious or other videos get
uploaded thanks for watching
you